Evet şimdi bilimsel yöntem çok temel bir
konu o yüzden ben liselerde ne kadar
fazla meteorolojik olarak öğretilir onu
da bilmediğim için bazılarınıza bariz
gelebilecek bazılarınızı da yaptım
yapmanıza rağmen aç fark etmediğiniz
birkaç tane şeyden bahsetmek istiyorum
şimdi bilimsel yöntem derken kastımız
bir şekilde gerçekliği bulma yolunda
attığımız adımların bütünü bu gerçekliği
bulmak veya bilgi üretmek dediğimizde
bunu birkaç farklı yöntemle
yapabilirsiniz bilimsel yöntem bunların
arasında çalıştığını bildiğimiz
gözlemsel olarak gösterebileceğimiz ve
insanların nesnel olarak üzerinde
mutabık alabildiği kültürlerinden
Mekandan ve zamandan bağımsız olarak
üzerinde ufaklık olabildiği yegane
ve bilim üretme yöntemi bilgi üretme
yöntemidir bilimsel yöntem ve belirli
Aslında Kural demeyelim ama meteorolojik
özellikleri vardır O yüzden Bunlardan en
azından bir tanesini uyguladığınızda
bilim tanımının dışına çıkar bazen
sınırbilim olursunuz bazen de sözde
bilim olursunuz Hatta doğrudan bilim
dışı yaklaşımlar da bulunabilirsiniz o
yüzden bu Metro dönecek yaklaşmam Bence
bilinmesine ve bak tarafından
özümsenmesi çok büyük önem olduğunu
düşünüyorum Emek İster olarak şimdi bir
etmekten kastımız burada belirsizliği
azaltma sürece Yani şöyle düşünün
fikirler uzayında bile bileceğimiz her
şeyin bir arada düşündüğümüz Bir Uzay
hayal edin şekilde müzeye matematiksel
olarak kastediyorum bütünlük de Aslında
her şey hem başta
bu maksimum derecede belirsizlikle
başlıyor hiçbir şey bilmeden başlıyoruz
Yani hem uygarlık açısından hem de Bir
İnsan doğduğunda hiçbir şey bilmeden
başlıyor ve daha sonra yavaş yavaş bu
belirsizliği azaltıyoruz ve içteki
hiçbir alanda Aslında belirsizliği
tamamen sprey indir diyemiyoruz bu
kuantum mekaniğinde de böyle Ama genel
olarak bilgi toplarken belirli ölçüler
yapıyoruz her ölçüde aslında bir hata
payı var o yüzden no ben yani gibi benim
siz bir azaltma sürece olarak düşünmeyi
uygun görüyorum ve burada belirli önemli
noktalardan nesneler var konuşmamız
gereken bunlardan bir tanesi hipotes
hipotes kavramı çok önemli Çünkü siz
belirli bir gözlem yapıyorsunuz daha
sonra gözlemle karşılaştı
bu tahmin ihtiyacınız var gözlemle
tahmin bilmek en önemli iki nesne gözlem
yapıyorsunuz ver üretiyorsunuz bu bebeği
ile karşılaştırınız bir tahmin
ihtiyacınız vardır tahmin arka planını
oluşturan şey nasıl dikkat ediyoruz
Sizdeki protezi fikirler üzerinde
başlıyorsunuz gaz sonra eleme yöntemiyle
diyorsunuz ki bu olmalı bu olmalı bu
şekilde olmalı diyorsunuz belirli
tahminde buluyoruz bulunuyorsunuz bu
Tahminlerin bazıları ver ile
karşılaştırılabilir bazıları
karşılaştırılıyor karşılaştırma bilenler
arasından devam ettiğimizde demeli ile
karşılaştırdık da belirli bir eleme
yöntemi takip ediyoruz veri en önemli
şeyler bilim değerli bilimsel yöntemler
sizin fikrinizi hipotezini tahminidir
inanılmaz derecede zayıf olabilir çok
tahmin katilin edici olabilir Çok zekice
gözükebilir ama
bu çok önemli bir nokta vardır ki gözlem
süzgeçinden geçemeyecek hiç bir hipotez
yoktur yani geçmeme mutlu olan hiçbiri
protez yoktur Eninde sonunda belirleyici
şey gözlemdir ve bu gözleminde belirli
özellikleri vardır en önemlisi
tekrarlanabilir olmasıdır bir gözlem
tekrarlanabilir Eğer değilse çeşitli
gözlemciler aynı deneyi yapıp benzer
sonuçlara ulaşamıyor sana o zaman
gözleminde Aslında değiş kendimi kalmaz
Çünkü biliyoruz ki insan kendi
içerisinde sürecektir yargıları olan
öznel şekilde Dünya ile alanbey canlı ve
bu yüzden Bilimsel yöntemin doğru
çalışabilmesi için bu tür bir tekrarlana
bilme kavrama ihtiyaç var Çünkü çoğu
insan doğrudan kendi kişisel anne
kodlarıyla üreteceği bilgi ve gözlem
bu doğru kabul edemez Çünkü insanlar
çeşitli çıkarları yüzünden olsun tamamen
ilaçları doğrultusunda olsa kişisel
metodlarını Yanlış şekilde aksetme ya
satabilirler o yüzden birbirinden
bağımsız araştırma gruplarının
araştırmacıların gözlemcileri aynı şeyi
gözlemle bilmesi gerekir birçok önemli
bir şey daha atlamayın onu da söyleyeyim
ki koş konusunda tekrarlanabilirlik
Pardon ondan öncesi yanlışlanabilir
hipotezler açısından çok önemli bir şey
yanlışlanabilirlik çünkü bir protez
oluştururken yine çok önemli bir şey var
Her türlü protezi oluşturabilirsiniz az
önce söylediğim gibi çoğu tahminin
karşılaştırabilirsiniz bir verisi de
yoktur yani siz öyle bir protez
yazarsınız ki tamamen gözlemlenebilir
evrende hiçbir alakası olmayan kendi
başına kalmış
bu herşeyi tahmin edilen Belki çok
ilginç şeyler tahmin edebilen çok ilginç
şeylerin varlığını öngören ama bunların
Aslında gerçeklik Hiç alakası gözlemle
alakası olmayan şeyler olabilir ve
bunlarda bilimin gözünde aslında
değersizleşir Çünkü benzeyen Kanıt diye
bir kavram vardır teknik Detaylara
girmeyeceğim herhangi bir protezi
verinin ışığında Aslında
değerlendirebiliriz ve hatta diğer
hipotez diğer bütün protezler üzerindeki
diğer hipotezlerde karşılaştırabiliriz
Özlem karşılaştırma içerisinde belirli
hipoteze ne kadar kalın sunabiliyoruz ve
ışığında bunu sayısal bir düzleme bile
dökebiliriz O yüzden bu protezlerin
yanlışlanabilir olması Bu bakımdan
onların kanıtı miktarını arttırır yanlış
kalabilir protezler eğer doğru ömürler
de bulunuyor Biz olunabiliyor dersen o
zaman bilimsel yöntem doğal seçilim
sağlar bunları seçer
da herhangi bir protez düşünün her şey
tahmin ediyor gözlemlenebilir şeylerini
tahmin ediyor O zaman o elenir Çünkü
zaten Siz her şey tahmin ediyorsanız
tatlıya doğru yani beklenen olarak zaten
gözlemlenen şeyleri tahmin edeceksiniz
Eğer burada tabii ki geldi özellikle
Facebook olarak bazı Sözde filmlere çok
fazla böyle ve Detay olarak bilmek
istemiyorum ama söyle bilimlerin genel
olarak yaptığı şey budur şu genel
tahminlerde bulunurlar Aslında bilimsel
yöntemler ve bilimsel yöntem hiçbir
değerleri yoktur üzerine olmalarının
sebebi de budur